but what are you gonna do or you gonna
get a job or are you gonna leave the
house I'm gonna open that tattoo
restaurant no like for real it's never
been done before I looked it up
the movies so great you guys are both so
good in it ma died I just talked to your
dad and he said that you know it was
very interesting to direct you this time
around because the last time he directed
you he was just quote manipulating you
more than directing narrative so how did
it feel this time around I was like that
is actually kind of it um yeah I mean I
haven't worked with my dad in like ten
years
so it was really different I mean
working with him now obviously that I've
worked with other people and done other
things and coming back and I guess back
then I didn't fully realize what was
going on and now I feel like I'm taking
acting a lot more serious obviously and
ya know it was really great though and
really nice to work with him now that
I'm older and can watch how he works
from him more than I could at 12 do you
feel nerves being on set with your dad
or how does it feel
I always feel nervous and it's almost
worse because I want to do well for my
dad so she doesn't think that I think
that but I think that's important to me
and so I don't know if I'd say I was
nervous but I definitely yeah I wanted
to make sure I was doing a good job was
there a moment when you consciously said
I want to be an actress because you've
kind of been doing this since so young I
didn't know if it just happened or if
you thought no no no I want to follow
this path I literally don't I think I've
always known like I did theater in
elementary school like all through
school and in college and like yeah I
was never even a question I just I was
lucky to know like really young that
that was what I love doing most this is
both of you guys first time working with
Pete and the movies such a personal
story from for him Bell I'll go to you
what was it like to play somebody dating
Pete Davidson and your character gives
him a lot of straightforward feedback in
this movie dad that's why I love to
character so much I think historically
like the girlfriend role in a movie was
like a lot different from how like we
decided that Kelsey to be and she gives
him a lot of home
Kruse early on she doesn't put up with
this and like she doesn't she's like I'm
not gonna wait around for you to get
better and I'm not gonna save you like
you've gotta like work out your stuff
and Pete was a friend of mine before and
he's a good friend of my boyfriend and
it was just like amazing and I'm very
proud of him for making a movie that's
so close to him and his life you know it
was so kind of pretty like incredible
experience and micro set to work on you
know that you're making something that's
so close he and his family on set even
did they help you with your Staten
Island accent they don't know that they
did because I'm listening closely yeah
his mom to me has like a really thick
accent so I definitely took some notes
somehow I was obsessed with Grandpa what
did you guys both think of Pete's
grandpa how much fun wave you I don't
need him more hands but watching him I
was like whoa I need to meet this guy he
killed it and also like I know Pete
loves his grandpa so much and like he's
the one who introduced Pete to like all
of his favorite movies and he loves
movies so much so I think it was like
really special to be able to see that
one set together and he was so proud and
it was really nice what I love about
this movie is you touch on the issues
like mental health and depression stuff
that everybody is dealing with and it's
coming out at this really volatile time
in our country so I was just wondering
how working on the movie maybe affected
both of you and what you might hope
people take away from it as a feeling of
connectivity or some advice for that I I
think what's so amazing about this film
what John does so amazing with all of
his movies is that it makes you laugh
but it also makes you think and it also
touches you so hey I hope that it gives
people like a little break it gives
people a laugh and these crazy horrific
times but also you know I think more
than I like a from a generation where
young people now like William to talk
more about that issues like grief and
mental health and we were to you know
topics at this film so I really hope
that you know it opens up conversations
about those important things Mahdi your
parents are both very outspoken people
they give their opinions on social
issues what have you learned from them
or what would you tell other young
people maybe about how to be part of the
conversation if they were
yeah I mean I think it's just educating
yourself and not just looking at
headlines but reading in-depth articles
and books and trying to learn as much as
you can before or not before just yeah
harness me okay I can tell you're your
father's daughter because that was the
exact same first thing he said to me
well suppose you'd always said to me and
so I've always tried to do that and now
I'm just open to like whatever
yeah just educating myself well you know
we also love you on Morning Show I'm
wondering if you can tell us anything
about another season or when you guys
might be able to get things going
we just started shooting when the
pandemic hit so we had to stop obviously
and I think they're working out right
now like when and how we can go back to
work and I'm sure the writers are like
seriously rewriting it to make it a
Felson well I hope so yeah yeah yeah
because I mean the show went through
that before such a rewrite yeah and in
the world said I mean I don't know
anything that was just my guess well we
can't wait for more the movie is again
it'll aft I cried all those things
watching it what was it like for you
guys to watch Pete make such a personal
film I was just talking to him he said
he hopes this would be a healing process
he hoped it would help people understand
him more what was it like to be part of
that to be on a set where you know how
important this story is and how
important it's told well and Pete was
always very supportive on set like he
never made I mean at least for me like
me feel like I was messing anything up
like he was just super supportive like
you did a great job and like a character
really yells at him yeah and like we
just had the best time doing no it
sounds weird but yeah no he was just
super supportive and we all knew a meant
a lot to him and everyone was on there
like a game just trying to do their best
work to make sure that we did a good job
I'm just proud of like him I think that
it's so brave what he's done and also
like you know people need to talk about
these issues and the guys I said before
like the subjects of like grief and
mental health for young people and
growing up when you like coming-of-age
but you can't let go of your past I
think it's incredibly brave Liam's like
use his own story for himself like on
the line
that in order to hopefully like help
people talk about things